[MUSIC]
Okay, it's just like that. It's 7 o'clock. You are listening to Redwood Community Radio,
KMUD Garberville, 91.1 FM in HD1, KMUE Eureka, 88.1 FM in HD1, KLAI Laytonville, 90.3 FM on
the web, KMUD.org and in shelter COVER at 99.5 on FM translator K258BQ.
Well, good evening and welcome to Ask Your Herb Doctor. This is June 17, 2022. My name
is Andrew Murray. My name is Sarah Johannesen Murray. So once again, welcome to the show
which runs from 7 to 8 o'clock and at 7.30 we open the lines up to invite callers in
with questions related to this month's topic which is going to be around food and the corporation's
control of food and some ongoing numbers and statistics from the COVID outfall and then
we're going to get into some parts of the political discourse and involvement in big
companies in the Ukraine and fertilizer production and then hopefully we're going to get to the
topic of the baby milk shortage, follow that up with some artificial meat topics and as
always have the great pleasure of having Dr. Peat's superb overview of a lot of things
and I guess it's part of his age that enables him to encompass 70, well he's certainly older
than that, but he encompasses at least 40-50 years of time spent studying the subjects
and another three decades on top of that of living for this amount of time to see the
events unfolding that have done. So he's got a pretty good rounded view of many different
subjects and obviously alternative medicine is one of them and he's been obviously spending
a large part of his life and his career looking at the research which is always the most interesting
part of any of this factual information, it's not just opinion. So once again I'm very pleased
to have Dr. Raymond Peat Joyce join us on the show. Dr. Peat are you there?
Yes.
Okay well if you don't mind me just for the next five minutes or so I just wanted to run
an introduction to some of the questions that I'll be asking you and getting your opinion
on, but just wanted to wrap up last month's discourse, we talked about genetic modification
and corporations with patent rights on intellectual property that they are saying, especially
Monsanto with their genetically engineered seeds and the quote unquote moratorium that
was on natural products, certainly symptoms have been put to one side now, where naturally
occurring products like corn, wheat and potatoes etc. Although they're natural they have now
been granted patent rights on their genetically modified versions of them and I think this
also runs into vaccine technology and obviously the emerging infections that we've gone through
since the late or mid 1990s up until now with Covid obviously being the major part of our
prior two year discourse on the events of Covid. I also wanted to remind people that
the lawyer Ryan Afformic is, well I think he's still presenting it but has a huge amount
of data on the website which I would encourage everyone to look at as a superb chronologically
documented series of allegations which essentially he's charging crimes against humanity for
many organizations, institutions and governments and that website is a secure website, https
colon forward slash forward slash radical r-a-t-i-c-a-l dot org forward slash pandemic parallax
view. That should get you there, there's a bit more in the URL but essentially radical
dot org and then pandemic parallax view. So lists every detail about the beginning from
the Wuhan lab, Fauci, the funding of it all up until the present point and why people
have been so hoodwinked over what's happened. I also mentioned last month that the United
Nations has changed the terminology from technocracy to green economy and sustainable development
and how that impacts us all very negatively because it sounds so innocuous and harmless
sustainable development. Who doesn't want sustainability? We all do, I do. I want local
markets, I want people growing food locally, I don't want huge corporations shipping food
from one side of the world to the other and displacing rural farmers. So we want sustainable
development but the words sustainable development have been couched in such a way as to embrace
this technocracy which we exposed last month as really beginning from about the 1920s and
Dr. Peat certainly weighed in on what he understands of technocracy having lived through it and
then obviously the Rockefeller Foundation and all the other power players that are forming
the heads of government institutions and global organizations from the Codex Alimentarius
series of programs that we did a long time ago. Rima Lebo has exposed that as being part
of a world government order to get us all to this point that we've heard recently about
the great reset. So anyway, that was just an overview of last month. I wanted just to open
up this month and I hadn't mentioned this earlier, Dr. Peat, but it's something that
caught my eye when I was looking at the information for this month's show that the fifth largest
life insurance company in the US has just paid out 163% more for deaths of working people,
folks not old people just ready to die, but working people from 18 to 64. So that group,
they paid out 163% more for deaths for that age group. So the company cites that non-pandemic
related morbidity and unusual claims adjustments is the explanation of losses from group life
insurance businesses and the stock is falling and the CEO is being replaced, et cetera,
and they're trying to prop this up. So the head of an Indianapolis based insurance company,
One America said the death rate is up a stunning 40% from pre-pandemic levels among working
age people. Now, five months after breaking this story of the CEO of One America Insurance
Company saying deaths among working people ages 18 to 64 were up 40% in the third quarter
of 21, a new report is out that a much larger life insurance company, namely Lincoln National,
reported 163% increase in death benefits paid out under its group life insurance policies
in 2021. To quote One America, the company's CEO, Scott Davidson, stated that we're seeing
right now the highest death rates we've seen in the history of this business, not just
at One America. The data is consistent across every player in the business. Now One America
is a $100 billion insurance company that has had its headquarters in Indianapolis since
1877. The company is approximately 2,400 employees and sells life insurance, including group
life insurance to employees and employers in the state. Now Davidson said the increase
in death represents huge, huge numbers and that it's not elderly people who die but primarily
working age people 18 through 64 who are the employees of companies that have group life
insurance plans through One America. And what we saw just in third quarter, we're seeing
it continue into fourth quarter and that is that death rates are up 40% over what they
were pre-pandemic. Just to give you an idea of how bad that is, a three sigma or a one
in 200 year catastrophe would be 10% increase over pre-pandemic. So 40% is just unheard of.
Now what is driving this unprecedented surge in "all cause mortality"? It was not only
deaths of working age people that shot up to unheard of levels in 2021 but also short
and long term disability claims. Now this holds true that the genetic vaccine so aggressively
promoted a failed and the clear federal campaign to prevent early treatment with life saving
drugs has contributed to a massive avoidable loss of life. At worst, this report implies
that the federal workplace vaccine mandates have driven what appear to be a true crime
against humanity. Massive loss of life in presumably workers that have been forced to
accept a toxic vaccine at higher frequency relative to the general population of Indiana.
And furthermore, we've also been living through the most massive globally coordinated propaganda
and censorship campaign in the history of the human race. All major mass media and the
social media technology companies have coordinated to stifle and suppress any discussion of the
risks of the genetic vaccines and/or alternative early treatments. Between artificial intelligence
powered algorithms and social media tech giants complicit in their communist style suppression
of information, we've witnessed an avoidable mass casualty event, needlessly caused by
a mandated experimental medical procedure which obliterated and eviscerated the First Amendment
of the Constitution of the United States in the process. How you may well ask yourself
did this happen? By deceit, collusion and corruption, all tools used by evil people
with wicked intent against their brothers and sisters, an international corrupt cabal
as well as by our very own complacency and failure to speak out en masse.
So, Dr. P, with that introduction, I'm sure it's not news to you. And they've been pretty
tirelessly talking about this since the very beginning of 2020. What are your interpretations
of this insurance company's disclosure of these facts revealed by public records request?
It wasn't freely sent out, but a company requested this.
All other companies since then have reported very similar increased mortality, around 40%
in the working-age group. And so, insurance companies generally have extremely accurate
statistics better than governments as a rule, because their income depends on exactness.
And so, it's really the scientific basis for saying that it wasn't the virus that's
responsible for the vaccination. That's when the 40% rise began. And it fits the virologists.
The skeptical virologists have been claiming that the mortality is going to be far, far
worse from the vaccine than from whatever occurred from the virus.
I think that was the point that was made mentioned, that it was all cause mortality in young people.
And a lot of it was to do with damage and disability. So, whether the death may have
been caused by the vaccine or not, the amount of money paid out due to the disabilities
that were claimed. I think this is a pretty stunning part of the numbers that we use to
cite the payments. And I think we've mentioned in the past that when we're describing things
like mortality and altitude, it was the very insurance companies that actually let that
information out, which supported that claim, that lower premiums were basically imposed
on people who are high of altitude because they really were not as likely as people at
sea level to die. Yeah. Okay. So, that's the first thing to see some kind of glaring headlines
about deaths and insurance companies making payouts and how this is now just part of the
fallout of COVID and everything that happened to quote, unquote, try to mitigate this virus.
Anyway, so that's been a fairly long process here for the last two years now. And supposedly,
now what we're seeing, and not supposedly, but I think it's the actuality of it all with
Omicron, whether or not Omicron, I don't know, if you feel that whether or not your opinion
is that Omicron is a naturally produced variant or indeed any other type of-
It has the most bizarre gene sequences of all of the other variants because starting
with the Wuhan, the other variants show a series of mutations building on each other. So, the
most recent until Omicron showed exactly the same series of mutations incorporated. So,
it was definitely that virus improving its survivability by mutating. But the Omicron
is unique. It didn't show any mutations after Wuhan or the Wuhan virus was going through
all of these changes. Nothing was happening at all to the Omicron. Suddenly, when it pops
up, it's essentially the pristine Wuhan virus with a new series built right on the original
virus. None of the history of natural mutation was being held aside and going through a different
series of mutations that wasn't in the world at all for these intervening years.
So, are you saying that basically the original COVID went through mutations and you can track
that? And then all of a sudden, Omicron was like the original with just some alterations
to it. So, it looked like it had been lab produced or produced in a lab?
And those mutations made it much less harmful. So, it was if someone was preparing a product
to end the pandemic by turning it off with a fairly harmless virus.
So do you think that if people have Omicron and they've developed antibodies to that and
caught that naturally, even though it's not a naturally mutated virus, then will they be
better able to fight the original Delta or those other variants?
No, it won't especially affect them. If it's a dominant virus and it's very harmless, then
the other one just isn't going to be around to cause trouble.
Okay you're listening to Ask Your Herb Doctor, KMUD Garberville, 91.1 FM. From 7.30 to the end of the show, callers
are invited to call in with any questions either related to this month's discussion
or indeed any other questions they'd like to pose to Dr. Peat about health-related or "alternative
medicine." The number is 707-923-3911. So from 7.30 to the end of the show, 8 o'clock, callers
call in to 707-923-3911.
Okay, so moving on to the kind of major content of this next 40 minutes, 45 minutes, I read
an article about the Oakland Institute and this was a 2014 article. And the article certainly
- yeah, nearly eight years later - what we're seeing now in Ukraine and Russia, it's kind
of not really a political question, but you know, it's really a question that's embroiled
in health and government control and takeovers and, you know, aggressive campaigning of which,
you know, people have certainly heard a lot about Roundup and Monsanto and we've all heard
about GMO and Monsanto and it's a huge corporation. So the Oakland Institute, like I said, published
a 2014 paper outlining what was being described then as a global corporate takeover of agricultural
land in the Ukraine. And when you look at Ukraine, it's been hailed as the breadbasket
of Europe with a staggering 32 million-plus hectares of incredibly fertile black arable
soil. Now, for those of you who are gardeners or horticulturists or farmers, you're well
aware of what this means to crops planted. In short, lush, rich fertile growth with excellent
crop yields and quality harvests. If you too are Monsanto, one of the biggest agribusinesses
on the planet or one of a handful of other players buying into this hugely profitable
location, rights to ownership and to play this game is extremely lucrative and corruption
as always exists at the highest level for the highest returns naturally. Ukraine's agricultural
land was under a moratorium that banned its sale through January 1st, 2016. And when Ukraine
separated from the Soviet Union in 1990, collectivized communal farms were disbanded and land was
distributed in parcels of approximately four hectares each to people living on the collectivized
farms. In 2001, Ukraine passed its land code legislation that gave people functional titles
to land. And since then, there's been a moratorium on the sale of land, which as noted was extended
through January 1st, 2016. The moratorium on land sales applies only to agricultural
land making it both legal and affordable for investors to build and operate a 100% foreign
owned processing facility on its own industrial land while leasing fields from agricultural
landowners until the moratorium on the sale of agricultural land was lifted. A second
way that investors could circumvent the land moratorium was by buying shares of large existing
Ukrainian agribusinesses. The system of land distribution in the 1990s often led to the
concentration of land in the hand of a few elites. Alongside land, opportunities in Ukraine
for development, production and the use of agricultural inputs like seeds, agrochemicals
and fertilizers have attracted investment by agribusiness giants Monsanto, Cargill,
DuPont and others. So I was going to ask you, Dr. Peat., you had lots of other information
to tie this. Everyone has heard about the International Monetary Fund offering the Ukraine
a $40 billion loan if they would stop the moratorium specifically so Monsanto and the
other giant corporations could concentrate ownership on the big corporate scale and that
there was a coup to make that happen because the elected president had rejected the IMF
fund and the IMF, working with World Bank and all of the other so-called Western authorities,
wanted to reverse that stop the moratorium and so they supported the coup. The coup was
very clear that they were going to adapt laws that would let Monsanto take over. When the
coup happened in fact that did take place and so they had to get rid of the legally
elected president and establish the Zelensky government supporting the Monsanto privatization
coup system. So how do you see Russia's involvement? I mean there seems to be a two-sided story.
Some people say that the Ukraine from a political and/or ownership geographical perspective.
Well part of the Monsanto thing is that they want to use chemicals wrapped around them
that are safe and favorable to them and the European Union had to oppose the United States
policy of supporting Monsanto and genetic modification and so there was a conflict between
Western Europe who had quite a lot of resistance. Several European, Western European countries
went along with wanting to outlaw GMOs and that was creating stresses between Western
Europe and the anti-GMO people and it turned out that historically Russia had been passing
the laws to promote organic farming and to outlaw GMOs and so they were aiming for 100%
freedom from GMOs and naturally from Monsanto. That really was the polarization for the coup,
for the International Monetary Fund loan when the elected president made the deal with Russia
for a loan that would bypass the International Monetary Fund. The actual moment when the
coup took place and got him out of Ukraine.
I read a couple of years ago, he can back me up on this, that Vladimir Putin was boasting
that he was going to make Russia one of the if not the biggest organic food producer in
the world.
Yeah, that's what one of his goals was. I thought GMOs are still banned in Europe.
Well, I think they are in England. I'm pretty sure England has banned GMOs.
No, I thought in England they're not banned because they're not part of the EU, so the
EU has banned GMOs. Is that what you're understanding, Dr. Peat?
We are wobbling on the issue that there are still opposition to it but now the war for
Monsanto has affected the west and they aren't pushing so hard to oppose the GMOs.
I wonder how the whole fertilizer shortage, again, apparently Ukraine is a big export or
manufacture of fertilizer. I wonder how that plays into it along with the agricultural
rich diversity that there is possible there in Ukraine and how this quote unquote food
shortages now they're talking about. Before we get into the subject of baby milk, the
food shortage issue, I wonder how politically motivated this is in terms of calling.
Oh, you can see many specific things in which it's been just openly promoted. For example,
again, Pacific Railroad announced that they just weren't going to ship all of the fertilizer
that the farmers needed. That preceded by several weeks the announcement that they were
not going to allow the shipment and sale of urea which is used in the diesel motors of
trucks by restricting the availability of this urea fuel modifier that they can turn
off truck delivery too but as a railroad since they said they're not going to ship all of
the fertilizer that's ordered. And why did they say that? No one knows but it seems to
be that they are controlled by black rock giant funds. Black rock. That is also just
openly intending to turn off the food economy. So they want to create a shortage for some
monetary gain. Oh, yeah. If you look at the pattern over the last several years when at
the very just weeks before the pandemic cloud swab was saying well, we've done our best
to use the carbon dioxide climate change mistake on science to fulfill our purpose of controlling
the overall production but now luckily we've got something much, much better that in just
a period of two or three years we'll be able to turn off the national and world production
of everything, the ordinary daily economy including food and all of the necessary supply.
I mean you can't make this stuff up and this reminds me of the whole discourse that I first
heard with Rema Labo back in 2006 I think it was, Codex Alimentarius and how the entire
thing is essentially a playbook from the end of the war or just before that really with
the emergence of technocracy through to global governments and one world currency. It's all
been documented and the way she was talking back in 2006, obviously blew me away. I couldn't
believe what I was hearing. Is this totally fantasy or is this, you know, I started looking
into it and the more you look at it, the more connections you see and so when we get things
like the war in Ukraine and we hear, well actually maybe, you know, Russia deciding on
the side of organic production and, you know, yeah, it was part of form of Russia and so
what really is the problem, I mean obviously there's a problem with people dying, don't
get me wrong, I'm not condoning war, but the reasons by which this happened are serious
government evil prospects and control and manipulation of the populations of various
countries to produce the narrative they want and that's exactly what social media has sought
to bring about since it all came out for Facebook and YouTube and all of the glorious technology
of social media, you know, the advent of it. Back in 2009 or so when the iPhones were becoming
really popular and the software to do this was connecting all these people like never
before so it kind of, you know, it may sound a little scary to people that are just listening
to it but there's a lot more in it and unfortunately I don't think there's a huge amount we can
do about it except peacefully protest and I think that's the saddest part of what I've
witnessed going through these last two years is that there's such a polarization, there's
such a control of information on the one hand that people are not getting the full information.
I just heard today that Simone Gold, one of the doctors in LA of the American frontline
doctors who were organizing, you know, patient consultations and alternatives to Covid treatments
that were, you know, the experimental drugs, she's just been in prison for two months and
this was all part and parcel of her 2020 appearance at the state capitol and her - Peaceful protest.
Yeah, peaceful protest basically saying that she objected to what was going on and that
the whole thing about free speech is like if we're not careful folks it's gone, you
know, and getting ratted out by your neighbor is in and the Soviet style era of people watching
people and people policing each other is kind of a scary reality which I think is crept
in so pervasively with this Covid "pandemic" that most people are looking, I don't know,
I'm not quite sure where they're getting their information from that's countering this narrative
that we hear about because it's everywhere you look. I mean to find an alternative view
on the Covid scenario is the kind of exception. Anyway, you're listening to Ask Europe Doctor
on KMED Galveston 91.1 FM. From now until 8 o'clock the lines are open, the number 707-923-3911.
Once again 707-923-3911. Okay, so getting to the milk crisis, the baby milk crisis, I
wonder what your opinion of this is because I know you've definitely got lots to say about
soy and PUFAs and all of these things. I mean from a perspective of making money from a
corporate perspective of mothers in Africa and I'm not saying that women that have children
that don't produce enough milk shouldn't be helped, of course not, but there are other
alternatives to formula. So what do you think about this baby formula crisis and it may be
not a bad thing? The soy formula had its own terrible side effect in immature animals.
The estrogenic factors associated with the proteins used in making the milk substitute
cause deformed genitals in the developing young and later promote tumors of various sorts.
So the plant-based milk formulas were a terrible problem in themselves and Benzi's Nestle
Innovations basically selling dehydrated cow milk as a basis for people around the world
to mix up at home to produce a liquid milk substitute despite the fact that clean water
to mix it with is absent in so many of the poor countries. So they were doing something
very counter-social in the interest but even in the US where people couldn't make a formula
themselves if they really couldn't produce milk they could simply make a formula based
on cow milk and when it isn't dehydrated the reaction on the immune system is less harmful.
The reaction right at the very beginning will cause some antigenic differences but at least
if it's made from fresh cow milk that's a lot safer than dehydrating because every time
you dehydrate a living substance you kill it and oxidize some of the proteins, amino
acids and especially the fatty acids the cholesterol is oxidized that's really only one of the
fairly trivial problems of dehydrated milk. The cholesterol is damage made toxic but many
other components of the milk are susceptible to oxidative damage and there is a whole anti-science
that has grown up to defend the industry's use not only of dehydrated milk but of the
added unsaturated fatty acids which is really a separate issue because they argue that human
milk contains more proof than cow milk and that has been a separate industry to say that
the baby must be given a supplement of N-3 fatty acids because they say almost all babies
at birth have evidence of a deficiency of N-3 fatty acids.
That's because the placenta has filtered it out.
Yeah exactly. It's recognized as something to be excluded during pregnancy but they reverse
that and say you need to supplement everyone because everyone is deficient.
Because the body naturally tries to keep it away from the baby, you're deficient that's
just the rationale is insane.
And to say that the aged brain contains increased amounts of N-3 proof and so they are wanting
to say that because you find it in the old brain that means it should be there but meanwhile
the old brain has deteriorated in proportion to the reduction of mitochondrial energy production
and that reduction corresponds to the increased presence of N-3 proof in the brain so at every
point they've twisted the science and one of the ways they twist it is with a certain
test of retinal responsiveness to electrical stimulation and they say if you increase that
your added proof, you're going to show that that addition makes the eye develop faster
and the brain developing mental ability sooner but that is all this sanity speculation.
Okay we got a call that came in apparently the caller wanted to ask a question off the
air so before we go to this next question the lines are open 707-923-3911 is the number
to call.
So okay what was the question that was being asked?
So the caller wanted to know if you could talk about some good things for Menopause
such as she's having brain fog and nausea.
Well ginger is always great for nausea.
Brain fog, okay so good nootropics, I don't know how supportive you are of nootropics outside
of using anti-stress substances like pregnant alone for decreasing cortisol and for decreasing
inflammation but what would your response to that be?
Oh yeah all of those things, coffee for example, aspirin, things that promote mitochondrial
oxidative use.
And herbal support would be Vitex, Chase Treeberry and black cohosh those are very effective
at helping mitigate the menopausal symptoms.
Okay so let's go on to the next question I don't know if we've finished the milk.
Yeah doctor I wanted to ask a question about the milk so all baby formula is dehydrated
milk or dehydrated not to say it's all dehydrated so when you say make a formula out of milk
would you suggest adding anything to cow milk?
Fresh cow milk?
Yeah you can adjust the amount of fat and water if it makes it more palatable to the
baby but just as is it'll work.
And so what about this talk in the news of a synthetic breast milk, what do you think
of that?
Oh it definitely works.
Do you think that would be preferable to cow's milk for babies?
Oh sure yeah, human well assuming that the mother is eating properly because the human
milk reflects the human plant because we don't have a rumen.
The cow can eat grass and weeds and quite a lot of polyunsaturated fats and detoxifies
them in the rumen so as a rule you can say that if the woman is eating well then her
milk is going to be better than cow's milk.
Right so the question I was asking is of course we all know that mama's milk, breast milk
is preferable for a baby or the best but with a healthy diet but I've read about them making
breast milk in a laboratory trying to synthesize breast milk in a lab.
I was wondering what your thoughts were on that?
Well probably not good, I might have certain similarities to breast milk but it's definitely
going to be a synthetic material chemical.
What about a subject of artificial meat and again between milk and meat and cancelling
out substances like sugar they must say quote they who are they but the industry and whoever
is behind the industry is seeking I think to separate people from their natural world
and I'm not saying oh everyone needs to drink milk but I am saying that milk is an extremely
good food and I think there's so much evidence to support its use that the whole demonisation
of it is really the same kind of skewing the information that you've given previous examples
of in research.
You've mentioned recently about protein intake for older people necessarily needing to be
decreased and that that's not a bad thing so what about that in terms of the amount
of you've never been big on muscle meat per se you've always encouraged people to use
the whole animal getting the gelatin from making a broth for example of chicken or knuckle
bones or you know lamb shank.
Yeah for many years people have been aware that with aging the metabolic rate slows down
and Brode Barnes was thinking about that and the importance of the metabolic rate and he
had been using a supplement of I think two grains of Armour Thyroid and he decided
to go on a high protein diet when he was around 60 I think and found that he had to double
his dose of thyroid hormone to maintain his functioning showing that for an older person
what seems to be a good level of protein can actually be very powerfully suppressive to
your thyroid function.
Okay so we've talked about things like soy protein in the past being used as a meat alternative
we know that's definitely not a beneficial substance in terms of raising estrogen in
men and women and being relatively inflammatory in its own right so I think it's just part
and parcel of our human nature and I think this really for me it's kind of speaking to
the buyer beware mentality that I think everyone needs to try and hang on to and remember because
I think it's just like social media and technology we're kind of cajoled and lured into this
kind of seemingly fuzzy world of comfortable technology and we're really just sucking down
so much poison that I think it's like being on drugs that are completely separating you
from reality in terms of what's actually going on around you that you don't say anything
and you're just cajoled and fuzzily oh it's okay if the government knows what they're
doing this covid vaccines a good thing that saves lives what you're talking about you're
the crazy one I'll bring that subject back out in a moment here but we do have another
caller on the air so let's take this next call a call away from and what's your question
I'm from the Arcata area I just wanted to make a comment kind of looking at the general
trend of things in this country where you know big corporations or want to control everything
or at least the bulk of the economy so it had to do with seeds basically you guys were
talking about food and growing organic vegetables and stuff like that and I was surprised talking
to one of the vendors at the farmer's market that she had to buy seeds I don't know if
it's some kind of licensed type of thing but just looking at the trend of how things are
evolving I would expect that over time you know the seed supply is going to be controlled
by completely controlled or mostly controlled by big companies and it would behoove people
to learn how to make their own seed you know grow their own seed save seed and try to keep
it from being contaminated with I'm sure genes that are going to be inserted to either you
know make it so you could only grow seed and it won't reproduce or what have you so I guess
that was my comment just moving forward that's a good thing for people to try to explore
thank you for your show yeah you're welcome thank you for your call okay yeah so I want
to just kind of run follow up that that call with you know this really applies to people
that are fortunate enough you know to have a garden I'm not talking about acres of land
but I'm just talking about people that have a small garden you know to grow vegetables
in because obviously you know and we've all known it and it's happened in China quite
successfully where millions and millions upon hundreds of millions of people were pulled
out of rural agrarian locations and brought to the cities it's all about the cities and
it's all about the mass media control they have over populations when you're in the cities
and under their domain and you don't have a garden and you don't have a connection to
the natural world that's when all of this is breaking down that's I think very very
similar to you know some of the kind of biblical references to that very same subject and like
the Tower of Babel and how all of this was just a mass of confusion and you know God
made it impossible for them to understand each other and that was because they just
wanted to get on with it without God and they didn't feel they needed any kind of natural
creation they could do without all of that and I think unfortunately it's a kind of side
effect of our humanism that you know we don't you know we're kind of numbed and I think
so many people unfortunately are just sucking it down you know and yeah I find it hard to
believe in some ways that they're pulling it off but I think what's happening really
is a concerted and orchestrated attempt and we're not even attempt I think they're doing
it is an orchestrated play and we're going through the motions but I'd never give up
and I would encourage everybody listening never to give up they never as far as I'm
concerned they're never going to win you just have to keep resisting and keep resisting
for the very end because the end is not the end okay so yeah I'm Dr. Peatagain like you've
been you've been around quite a while now and you've seen governments come and go and
heads of state come and go and you've seen lots of headlines and politics etc and I know
I just ask you in these last few closing moments about your impression yeah is there any hope
of the world what do you what do you think about it I mean I know we still we're still
alive and we're still trying to do the right thing but um where are you where are you with
all of this I'm still hopeful good like Reiner fuel mesh said we have to do everything
legal and impossible to try to prosecute these people but at some point he's going to
count on a some kind of a cosmic bailout for us
Reiner is counting on a cosmic bailout yeah I forget his exact phrase but
interesting he said he couldn't explain it rationally but he had this confidence that
the universe wasn't going to let that turn out the way the world economic federation hopes
or the IMF okay well well that's helpful there's there's hope then yeah we're good I appreciate
your time uh joining us on the show and uh only only sad that we didn't have more callers but I
can only hope it's a busy weekend people have rodeo and the summer arts fair and that's local
I can only hope that people are the oyster fest listening and not calling in but I can always say
the archive is there for people to listen to in the future and the future will vindicate
what you've said for a long time so thanks so much again Dr Peat for joining us okay thank you
thank you and good night okay so I just wanted to kind of finish off from saying that this this
connection is undoubtable you know between technocracy and dehumanization through lockdowns
and social isolation so with government coercive measures and soviet era style social control where
individuals are set against individuals similar also to the brown shirts of
nazi germany the Orwellian reality we are now in and which unless it's resisted will become
de facto the new normal and must be resisted vehemently through peaceful protest and political
involvement on the state and local level needs to occur it's the reason we need another hagen
charges of international war crimes against humanity where the guilty are charged and why
rhinophomics group in germany is at this very moment pressing these charges so the thing is
ongoing I like to think that there is a real justice and that we're not just going to be
sucked into the matrix we're not going to have any any any uh any way through it so did he say
there's someone else he wanted to ask a question well I think Dr Peat's probably hung up by now
anyway hello yeah go ahead we've got three minutes as well to the top of the hour okay a couple of
things uh one is um the uh I don't even think we've got time we've got three minutes it's not going
to happen I'm so sorry okay we better we better call this it because we'll run over and so I
basically I want to know okay they say that an ounce of prevention is worth a pound of cure and
you seem to think that uh getting some kind of treatment is better than getting a vaccine to
prevent the covid and you know I would rather not get it than have to you know get it and be treated
for it but so I'd like to an answer to that question and also basically why do you think
that the vaccine is worse for you than the covid itself uh the information's out there for anybody
who's wants to search for it so it's not something you're going to see on your facebook group or on
your youtube channel or google or the fact checkers that check that work for google and it is two
minutes the top of the hour so I need to give credit to Dr Peat and his website and his
information so I appreciate your call but don't have time to answer it I'm sorry so okay for those
of you who've listened to the show they run every third Friday of the month from seven to late pm
we'll be back in july we're coming up to solstice now so we run a business called
western botanical medicine and Dr Raymond Peat his website is Ray Peat r-a-y-p-e-a-t dot com
and he has got plenty of scientific reference articles that are not his opinion but are pulled
from current medical journals or past medical journals medical research trials etc etc and again
may not be something that you'll find on your facebook group or if you just google it up until
this point you're probably not going to find it and some of it's going to be censored and we're
probably moving into a more censored environment as we go on folks so people just watch out you
know uh anyway without being alarmed Mr Valley my name's Andrew Murray and we'll talk to you again
in july my name is Sarah Johannesen Murray thank you for listening
you